I guess Cory that this really speaks to
Steph Curry's social media presence and
his power in that that arena certainly
mean he's got 20 million social media
followers and so that instantly turns
itself into a market with something like
this ships it's the right thing at the
right time for the right audience and a
big one I mean outselling the Kim
Kardashian's emoji app which is which
was my favorite until Steph's came out
now to get the $1 99 app as well the
thing about Steph Curry though it's not
just him it's his entire family right
his wife is a host on the Food Network
his daughter is a media sensation as
well Riley we love us some Riley across
the country she's at a national star as
she hijacked a press conference during
the NBA Finals last year yeah well I
think this also speaks to you know who
the NBA is appealing to of course Steph
Curry winning his second MVP last week
going to a second NBA Finals right now
it's a feat only the chance to win the
finals two years ago and and be the MVP
tears roll has only been done by LeBron
James Michael Jordan Wilt Chamberlain
that's our bills are Bill Russell that's
your list those three guys so it's kind
of an all-time moment the notion that
the this emojis this wonderful way of
communicating that has captured the
minds of Millennials everywhere is is
added to that it's it is the kind of
right product it's it's the reason that
this thing is doing so well and how its
selling yes even the great Kim
Kardashian even the great Kim Kardashian
okay so it's a dollar ninety-nine for
this Steph emoji keyboard but who
actually gets paid who's making this on
his behalf what are the companies
involved well apples gonna of course
take a lot of money from this they they
get a 30% cut of everything sold in
their Apple iTunes store so all those
absolutely at 30 percent of that stuff's
probably getting a licensing deal from
this as well but it lends itself to sort
of you know as people communicate using
Steph then Steph currently current Steph
Curry is the social currency of the
moment and that only accrues back to him
and maybe even back to underarmour
probably his chief financial backer next
to the Golden State Warriors